Don't tubers continuously shed cancer cells. I think they're talking about tubers cells. They're
shedding circulating tubers cells. It's hard to imagine that they do that and fits and spurs,
but maybe they do. I think it's hard to imagine that tubers will release circulating tubers cells
in pulses or spurs, but maybe they do. But if they shed continuously, then why would anyone ever
have zero circulating tubers cells if they do have a tumor? Even if some have moved on
to tissue or to the liver, there shouldn't still be some in the blood if they're being continuously
no. There's no data that tells us how and when growing tubers will most likely be releasing
circulating tubers cells. I have said over the years that I don't put a lot of faith in the
circulating tubers cell test because I have just seen through my patient-based
patients that have done the circulating tubers cell test have come back with elevated
circulating tubers cells but no other evidence of cancer growth or the opposite. They've come back
with no circulating tubers cell evidence in the test and yet have all sorts of other evidence
of tumor growth. So given that data, then I would say that for someone to have zero circulating
tubers cells in the blood is not a typically valid test to say that the person doesn't have any
cancer growth or the cancer is dead or the cancer is walled off. Again, like any lab that you do,
any lab has variables and any lab is there to give you clues. It gives you ideas. Nothing's
going to be perfect. I'm going to do this test and this is going to tell me if I'm cancer
for you or this is going to tell me if my cancer is growing like crazy. None of that one test is
going to be perfect in that scenario. Even your gold standard PET scan, you could have a very rapidly
growing new tumor that is metastasized in your liver, let's say, but it's still only two million
cells large and it's not picked up by the PET scan so you could be given a no evidence of disease
from your oncologist and yet you have a lot of evidence of disease. You have a lot of disease,
they just haven't found the evidence yet. So that's why they term it that way. The test doesn't show
that there's cancer. It doesn't mean that there's not cancer. Likewise, you could have something
light up on a PET scan and yet it was just metabolically active at that time of the PET scan. It's not
really actively growing. That's why you want to compare with other previous tests. If you have a
previous PET scan to see, okay, let's look at the size while it is metabolically active in the lung
here, but it's actually smaller than it was before or it's much larger than it was before. So you're
getting these clues from these tests and you look at other labs. Well, as this is the alkaline
phosphatase code up, as the calcium levels code up is it? So no test, I know we all want. I just want
to run this test and know exactly where I'm at. Well, I could lie to you. I mean, oncologists tend
to do that a lot. They just tell you what you want to hear, but that's not true. So I just want to be
giving you real data that is not as possible. None of these tests are going to be perfect. None of
these tests can just call my heart and we're all, okay, there are none of these tests should cause us
to freak out because we just don't know the full story and we're not at that place in modern medicine
yet that is going to give us that full data yet. So you have to use differential diagnosis and use
as much data as you possibly can to come to the best conclusion to make a decision whether you
should change treatment and to what degree you should try and change the treatment that you're
already doing. So sometimes I think that, you know, I know as humans, we want to know that everything
is black and white is my tumor turned on. There's a turn off. I just need to know and we need to know
this data and I know that some of us are more analytical and more linear than others than we want
to have this information because it really helps us in our decision-making process. And I'm
like that. That's me and the more you learn the more you learn that that's just not what life is like
and I think that sometimes God doesn't allow it to be like that because he it forces us to do either
dependent upon who we're going to put who are we going to put our faith in, you know, or we're going to
put our faith in the tester, we're going to put our faith in the treatment or we're going to put our
faith in the Lord Jesus and our heavenly Father that he's going to guide us. So during difficult times
of our life, whether it's cancer or it's financial issues or it's a death of the family, it has to
we have to let those things drive us to a deeper relationship with him so that we can
have that intimacy with our heavenly Father and that dependence upon that relationship.
So we can have peace in whatever decision that we're making. And I know, oh, that's two of two. So
I just don't want that. I want to get the science. I want the data. Well, that's just not what life
is about. So there's nothing wrong with seeking information. There's nothing wrong with learning
as much as you possibly can. But it all ends up bouncing back to we have to depend on the Lord. I'm
going to gain as much data as I possibly can. Knowing that science is imperfect and it's changing on a
daily basis. And then I have to ultimately fall back on my relationship with him and depend on him
for my answers.